un sapin aux couleurs de l'Ukraine pour
décorer la capitale un autre dans les
couloirs du métro de Quercy ville
devenue le symbole de la résistance
ukrainienne Noël 2022 sera forcément ici
différents des autres
habituellement en Ukraine la plupart des
orthodoxes suivent le calendrier russe
et faites Noël le 7 janvier mais cette
famille de ni pro a choisi de le
célébrer le 25 décembre c'est l'heure
des derniers préparatifs
leur motivation changer de calendrier
pour se rapprocher de l'Europe
maintenant le principal c'est de fêter
Noël avec l'Europe
de supprimer
et effacer tout ce qui nous ramène
tout ce qui nous relie à la Russie
leur souhait couper les ponts avec le
voisin russe car chaque jour dans cette
ville des familles sont frappées de
plein fouet par les réalités de la
guerre
presque tous les jours des femmes
entèrent leur fils leur mari ou encore
leur frère aujourd'hui cette grand-mère
doit dire adieu à son petit-fils il
n'avait que 23 ans
des drames qui ont aussi convaincu ce
prêtre de militaire auprès de ses
fidèles pour changer la date de Noël
afin de célébrer cette fête le même jour
que les chrétiens d'Europe
changer de calendrier de nous permettre
de montrer que nous sommes civilisés car
c'est un combat entre un monde civilisé
et un autre qui l'est beaucoup moins
une position partagée par de plus en
plus ukrainien selon un récent sondage
le nombre d'habitants souhaitant changer
la date de Noël à doubler en un an sur
ce panneau on peut lire nous célébrons
Noël avec l'ensemble du monde chrétien